[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique de la semaine au
sommaire la course aux parrainages alors
que les candidats doivent rassembler 500
signatures d'élus locaux pour se lancer
dans la course à la présidentielle le
système fait débat certains d'entre eux
affirment avoir des difficultés à les
obtenir comment expliquer qu emmanuel
macron pas encore candidat approche les
1000 parrainage alors que marine le pen
n'a rassemblé qu'une centaine
comment fonctionne le système des
parrainages est-il antidémocratique
comment les différents candidats
s'organisent
c'est le débat de la semaine alexis
poulin et jacques de guillebon vous
livrent ensuite leur actu du monde
d'après mais d'abord l'affrontement des
trois droites quelques jours après les
meetings de marine le pen et d'eric
zemmour et avant celui de valérie
pécresse ce week end ces trois candidats
sont au coude à coude dans les sondages
l'identité de celui ou celle qui
pourrait affronter emmanuel macron au
second tour est de plus en plus
incertaine qu'est ce qui les différencie
et les rassemble quelles sont leurs
visions de la droite celle actu des
éditos avec une première question
messieurs ils comptabilisent à eux trois
près de la moitié des intentions de vote
selon vous un rassemblement des droites
derrière celui ou celle qui atteindra le
second tour est il envisageable
bonjour alexis naujac heureux de vous
retrouver générer quelques semaines pour
répondre à la question un rassemblement
des droites est il envisageable c'est
assez paradoxal selon moi puisqu'on a
donc ces trois droites qui font presque
la moitié de l'électorat français
aujourd'hui si on les si on les
additionne qui sont représentés par
trois personnes qui ne se supportent pas
toutes les trois alors que leur
électorat n'ont jamais été aussi proches
c'est à dire que ce serait possible
électoralement s'il y avait un chef
charismatique y arriver et qu'il était
capable de parler à tout le monde une
sorte de nouveau nicolas sarkozy peut
être de rassembler cet électorat-là au
second tour mais actuellement vu ce que
sont les relations entre marine le pen
et eric zemmour et valérie pécresse et
vu qu'elles sont les tiraillements m à
l'intérieur de leur camp ça semble
inenvisageable et donc on va vers une
défaite de cette droite oui c'est
l'effet centrifugeuses du centre droit
macro nist qui a permis de rendre flous
la candidature de valérie pécresse qui
aurait pu être beaucoup plus simple la
victoire aussi une certaine victoire
d'eric ciotti lors de la primaire des
républicains et puis l'arrivée d'eric
zemmour dans le champ politique qui va
diviser encore davantage un électorat
qui était acquis à marine le pen donc
c'est vrai que pour ces trois droites
s'assumer et surtout s'unir ça paraît
compliqué chacun essaye d'avoir son
sillon en espérant être au second tour
et pouvoir battre mails macron cette
fois ci mais l'union au premier tour
permettrait peut-être justement d'éviter
qu'ils menaient le maquereau second tour
et là d'avoir peut-être hachoir entre
qui pécresse contre zemmour pécresse
contre le pen ou quoi encore pour voir
quelles sont finalement plus les droites
attendu par les français oui mais là on
voit qu'ils sont dans un mouchoir de
poche tous les trois c'est à dire qu'il
tourne autour de 40% depuis depuis un
mois eric zemmour est en remontée et
marine le pen stagnant et valérie
pécresse ayant de tendance à abc alors
que pourtant si on regarde dans les
marqueurs vraiment de ce qu'est la
droite la droite qui n'a jamais été
aussi à droite je pense depuis très
longtemps notamment sur le droit du sol
le regroupement familial là et me qui
sont vraiment ce que semblent attendre
lors leur électorat s'est réglé le
problème de l'immigration régler aussi
le problème de la sécurité qui est lié
dans la tête de leurs électeurs ils ont
à peu près tous les trois les mêmes les
mêmes propositions
donc les lecteurs se retrouvent avec 1,3
fois le même programme trois
personnalités fondamentalement
différente et c'est là-dessus sans doute
que va se jouer la différence c'est une
sensibilité c'est à dire que sur les
programmes ils sont à peu près d'accord
même sur le programme économique on va
dire plus de libéralisme sur
l'allongement de la durée du travail
enfin plein plein de choses qui font que
finalement on ne voit pas la différence
dans les programmes donc c'est la
différence dans les sensibilités avec un
côté plus européen plus macro nist on va
dire pour valérie pécresse et puis un
côté plus souverainiste pour marine le
pen et eric zemmour qui est le nouveau
avec le l'envi assumer d'en découdre
avec l'immigration qui va être ce son
cheval de bataille donc on voit bien que
à part ça
vu qu'aujourd'hui l'élection
présidentielle les programmes tout le
monde sans fissures dans l'impression
c'est vraiment changé par rapport aux
années précédentes
ça reste
finalement un vote d'adhésion un
discours qui n'aura rien finalement
d'engageant lead réels par rapport aux
réformes proposées et on voit d'ailleurs
que des candidats ont des propositions
totalement fantasque oui et puis il faut
voir les manoeuvres d'appareil qu'il ya
derrière par le p créée 6 mai quelque
chose un cas d'école c'est à dire que
personne n'arrive à identifier
exactement ce qu'est le décret cisme
donc valérie pécresse par ce manque de
notoriété ou de colonne vertébrale qu'on
lui prête essaye de se mettre dans les
pas un jour de jacques chirac qui sont
dix ans je suis chiraquienne et se fait
cogner immédiatement par nicolas sarkozy
qui selon des propos rapportés du figaro
lui reproche désir chiraquienne alors
que c'est lui qui l'a fait ministre lui
dit qu'il apportera pas son soutien
ainsi elle ne le cite pas plus lui grand
nicolas sarkozy elle a un directeur de
campagne patrick stefanini qui était
celui de françois fillon est elle au
fond est plutôt du pays c'est à dire
qu'elle est prise en fait entre 4 4
grands moments de la droite si on veut
dire elle n'arrive pas à s'inscrire
dedans et il ya eric ciotti qui la tire
plus vers la droite dans le dit c'est
mon passe quoi pour essayer de faire
croire qu'elle serait le chirac de se
passe quoi là ça sent que ça marche et
de l'autre côté elle a les centristes
comme jean christophe lagarde avec qui
elle essaye de s'allier qu'il attire
dans l'autre sens oui et qui ne vont pas
faire bon ménage avec eric ciotti donc
on voit bien que la synthèse ce qu'est
ce qu'elle est c'est fait au ps à une
époque avec françois hollande à droite
elle est très difficile parce que c'est
des camps qui ne peuvent pas s'entendre
et puis on voit aussi les défections qui
commence avec des calculs comme eric
woerth par exemple qui choisit de
soutenir emmanuel macron à quelques
jours de l'élection en misant plutôt sur
une victoire une réélection des malades
macron qu'une victoire de valérie
pécresse et combien vont faire ce choix
là avec la question des investitures
aussi c'est eric ciotti en charge des
investitures chez les républicains donc
ça ça doit fâcher certains des cadors et
des et des hauts cadres de d désiré
public qui attend des investitures qui
se disent cette fois ci je n'aurai pas
ma chance avec cette écurie là donc je
vais aller voir ailleurs c'est pas de la
politique qui plaît aux français c'est
ce qu'on appelle la politique
politicienne c'est ce qui fait je pense
aussi l'adhésion à eric zemmour parce
qu'il ya pas encore ce type de jeux
d'appareil et c'est ce qui fait que on
risque de voir encore beaucoup
d'abstention pour ce premier tour de la
présidentielle il n'y a pas ce jeux
d'appareil cher eric zemmour mais il ya
quand même aussi les défections venu un
petit peu d'élèves et surtout du
rassemblement national vers le parti
d'eric zemmour vers reconquête
s'inquiète encore un parti embryonnaires
parce que tout est à construire depuis
tout à construire mais c'est un parti
qui avait beaucoup d'argent a priori
assez énorme pour un candidat
dont c'est la première élection qui est
même au dessus de l'argent qui avait
levé emmanuel macron à la même époque
donc il ya cinq ans ce qui attire aussi
évidemment
décadent même si ça on ne peut pas leur
prêter uniquement ses intentions là mais
le fait que jérôme rivière gilbert
collard viennent du r'n plus même damien
rieu fin ce ne sont pas des des cadors
mais ce sont quand même des des cadres
que marine le pen avait réussi à
rassembler parce qu'ils venaient de même
d'autres partis
marine le pen avait fait il ya cinq ans
elle a pu le faire aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'elle a fait le vide autour
d'elle il reste elle même comme
candidate et tous les cadres partent
chercher chez eric zemmour dont il ya
aussi ces manoeuvres d'appareil là entre
les deux extrêmes droites si on peut
dire est qu'ils cherchent aussi déjà à
se partager des circonscriptions donc le
ca peut aussi se retourner à un moment
donné quand on joue contre eric zemmour
ces jeux là oui de toute façon
d'ailleurs c'est la kz2 la campagne de
marine le pen de dire seulement les
arrivistes et ceux qui veulent trouver
un poste vend cher eric zemmour et il va
s'en mordre les doigts ici on fait une
campagne à l'ancienne et on sait où on
va on est un parti reconnu
reste à voir que effectivement c'est
pourtant le mouvement qu'elle avait fait
marine le pen il ya quelques années le
pari aujourd'hui d'eric zemmour de
reconstituer une droite autour de
reconquête en disant de toute façon les
républicains sont finies parce que la
synthèse entre la garde et ciotti est
impossible et pécresse n'y arrivera pas
donc c'est un pari qui est possible
reste à voir comment il peut se faire et
quel sera le score de marine le pen au
1er et au premier tour aujourd'hui si
marine le pen évidemment n'est pas au
second tour c'est la fin du
rassemblement national ce sera très
difficile d'y est d'avoir une suite de
placer des députés à l'assemblée
nationale est de continuer sur ces bases
là sachant que une quatrième campagne
présidentielle pour marine le pen me
paraît quand même est assez hypothétique
oui oui c'est d'ailleurs le but des
émaux rien c'est dans une premier c'est
de détruire le rassemblement national
qui depuis 30 ans ou 40 ans empêche
toute autre bloc de droite nationale de
s'exprimer en fait donc c'est ça la
lutte qui aujourd'hui c'est qui va
mettre la main sur la droite nationale
qui représente quand même au moins 30%
voire 35 % de l'électorat c'est pour ça
que cherry zemmour on attend le
ralliement de marion maréchal qui
devrait se faire sans doute fin février
ou début mars il compte là dessus pour
mettre un dernier plongeon à marine le
pen mais marine le pen monte quand même
qu'elle résiste en tant que personnalité
on le voit dans son électorat qu'il
garde un électorat extrêmement populaire
que examen on n'arrive pas à prendre
réellement c'est elle la star des
campagnes et des
les petites villes périurbaines ils se
sont affrontés par par meeting
interposés samedi dernier et aucun des
deux n'a lâché ce faire les deux
meetings ont été à peu près réussi dit
marine le pen s'est posé en femme qui a
été victime elle-même du système
politique donc eric zemmour parler de
pouvoir d'achat donc on attend le
meeting de valérie pécresse qui va avoir
lieu samedi voir si elle arrive à se
placer à la même hauteur si elle arrive
à rassembler elle aussi un public acquis
mais on a peur que ce public il est
quand même plutôt plus de 70 ans les
jeunes ne sont pas là c'est sûr
ils sont plutôt chez mg aujourd'hui et
on voit bien que le problème de valérie
pécresse c'est justement de se démarquer
dans cette campagne qu'elle est qu'est
ce qu'elle apporte de différent du
maquereau nisme à la droite parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal à voir et les
mesures qu'elle propose sont les mêmes
on le disait tout à l'heure que les deux
autres candidats de droite et puis il y
à ce candidat de droite qui lui fait
surtout de l'ombre qui est emmanuel
macron qui a réussi quand même à
rassembler autour de lui durant son
mandat puisqu'il a commencé sur les
cendres du parti socialiste à rassembler
largement des cadres
juppéiste de la droite pour construire
son gouvernement et puis la suite donc
pour elle c'est extrêmement difficile
d'exister tant que mails macron est
aussi haut dans les sondages
place au débat de la semaine retour sur
le système des parrainages à tout juste
un mois du dépôt officiel certains
candidats remettent en cause ce système
de la vème république qui fêtera ses 80
ans en 2022 alors effet de communication
véritable problème démocratique pourquoi
certains candide en plus de difficultés
que d'autres même s'il rassemble plus
d'intentions de vote mais commençons par
nous intéresser à l'un des plus gros
reproche c'est au système des
parrainages la fin de l'anonymat des
parrains depuis 2000 16 messieurs cette
transparence vous paraît telle
problématique
oui cette transparence elle est
problématique et surtout elle est
récente c'est françois hollande qui
qu'il impose qu'il armait dans le jeu
politique pourquoi elle est
problématique parce que quand on est
maire d'une petite commune et que son
parrainage devient officiel listés sur
le site du conseil constitutionnel ça
peut être utilisé par des opposants pour
la prochaine campagne et donc ça peut
vous faire perdre votre poste de maire
lorsque c'était pas transparent que vous
donniez votre parrainage à qui vous
vouliez s'était finalement beaucoup plus
démocratique parce que ça ne pouvait pas
être utilisé contre vous aujourd'hui on
voit bien que il ya à la fois les partis
qui en jouent en bloquant ses
parrainages et puis il ya la peur des
élus de se dire si jamais je parraine un
candidat de coeur ou parce que j'ai
envie de ce que le jeu démocratique soit
ouvert et bien ça va me retomber dessus
où je vais me faire taper sur les doigts
par mon parti je suis en partie d'accord
avec vous et en partie non c'est sûr que
c'est un risque que prennent ces petits
maires de communes mais moi pendant a
parlé avec certains ils sont aussi
agacer certains qui vont donner leur
leurs parrainages sont aussi agacé qu'on
les traite de coire et de voir que leurs
autres les autres édiles et peur comme
ça et ils disent en fait on a eu quand
même des élus de la nation locaux on a
le droit d'assumer
ce qu'on veut dire et en plus c'est même
pas dans le conte séquentiel c'est même
pas appeler parrainage s'appelait
présentation c'est à dire ce sont des
élus du peuple qui présente un candidat
en lui dans leur légitimité c'est ça en
fait finalement et finalement quand vous
regarder dans le détail en a assez peu
qu'ils peuvent montrer qu'ils aient subi
à cause des communautés de communes à
cause des subventions des conseils
départementaux ou régionaux devraient
vexations ou de vrais privation de
subventions donc c'est peut-être aussi
un risque qui est un petit peu surestimé
je suis pas mère moi même donc je vais
pas parler à leur place mais que cuite
prennent eux-mêmes peut-être trop à
coeur et peut-être certains élus n'ont
pas du tout envie de présenter quelques
candidats que ce soit et ça peut jouer
aussi ça ou alors ils sont peut être
divisée eux-mêmes où ils savent pas mais
c'est moins je trouve que c'est un
risque qui pèse moins que ce qu'on dit
oui c'est pas un risque énorme mais
c'est un risque qu'il n'existait pas
donc ils permettaient plus rapidement
plus facilement de donner un parrainage
aujourd'hui on sent bien que c'est
extrêmement stratégique
sur l'échiquier national mais aussi au
sein du parti auquel on appartient alors
on peut utiliser en fonction de ses
mandats l'un ou l'autre mandat pour
parrainer ce qui permet d'être moins
visible si on est maire et qu'on utilise
celui de député de responsable
départemental ou autre mais ce système
des parrainages pose aussi la question
alors que le président est élu aux votes
au scrutin majoritaire et universel de
du vote censitaire finalement des grands
électeurs est ce que il peut exister
comme ça est-ce qu'il faut pas le revoir
moi je ne suis pas ce qu'était l'esprit
de la vème république à l'origine
réservé at il encore 58 c'était le cas
c'est quand 62e que le général de gaulle
décide que ce sera un suffrage voilà
universel direct on garde ce principe là
et si haut si on garde ce principe là
alors pourquoi ne pas le faire de
manière plus intelligente avec plus de
parrainage à ce moment là avec un
système aussi qui permettent de les
capter plus le plus longuement et pas
seulement sur ce mois là où ils vont en
un mois allait faire le tour de france
pour récolter les parrainages et puis
quelque chose d'extraordinaire enfin
quand vous avez un grand parti qui est
majoritaire et un président sortant il a
déjà mis le parrainage donc on voit bien
que c'est ridicule pour un président
sortant d'aller chercher des parrainages
il les a defacto et pour les grands
partis aussi le parti socialiste qui
n'existe pas dans cette campagne à dalgo
qui plafonne à 2 % dans les sondages a
déjà plus de 6 100 parrainages donc on
voit bien que c'est un jeu qui va
favoriser certains candidats par rapport
à donner c'est un jeu qui peut favoriser
les parties basses moment là il faudrait
que les parties prennent leurs
responsabilités face des vraies
primaires et puis utilise un vote
censitaire
oui bon mais c'est vous avez raison mais
il ya déjà les prix mais en fait ça
c'est sûr a ajouté à l'américaine à ce
système qui existait déjà acquis oui
contradictoires qui ne vous dit pas ce
que c'est à la fois des grands électeurs
et en même temps on vote encore au
suffrage universel direct à côté donc
c'est un peu contradictoire et on peut
ajouter que depuis 50 ans des candidats
d'extrême gauche comme celui de lutte
ouvrière à celle de lutte ouvrière scène
du trianon sur leurs parrainages et
qu'aujourd'hui je crois que nathalie
arthaud et
on a en tête elle est très très haut
parmi les parrainages alors qu'on sait
très bien sauf
sauf catastrophe qu'elle va faire 0 5%
et que c'est le même cas depuis depuis
50 ans donc j'ai rien contre eux
nathalie arthaud qu'elle se présente
mais le système ne semble pas
fonctionner là dessus pendant que des
candidats qui représente 15 à 20% ont
toujours du mal à trouver leur propre
parrainage ses oncles ce système la
montre ses limites là dedans il est
censé inhiber les candidatures
bizarroïde qui n'en recueilleront pas de
deux suffrages et c'est ça marche pas
mais non puisque le but des parrainages
justement c'était de limiter le nombre
de candidatures et de pas avoir de
candidature fantasque on a vu jusqu'à 16
candidatures à l'élection présidentielle
en 2002 donc on voit bien que ce système
là ne l'imitent rien revanche il devient
de plus en plus compliqué là où vous
aviez des candidats qui ne paie n'est
pas vrai que recueillir des parrainages
par exemple quelqu'un comme jacques
cheminade qui systématiquement se
présente et avait des parrainages ça va
être beaucoup plus compliqué cette année
marine le pen aussi qui chaque année
enfin solide at il été présenté en 2017
levallois était déjà voté oui donc il a
vu ses parrainages mais les avis oui là
mais cette année je suis pas sûr qu'il
pourra les avoir nicolas dupont aignan
ne les avait pas eu en 2007 donc ça
dépend vraiment et là enfin à chaque
fois on a ce psychodrame des parrainages
de dire voilà si on veut que la
démocratie soit il vante je dois avoir
mes parrainages or il ya un risque
encore accrue on l'a vu à gauche avec la
primaire populaire dont la stratégie de
cette primaire était d'empêcher
finalement pour faire l'union les
candidats de gauche d'avoir leur
parrainage pour n'avoir qu'un candidat
dé facto donc c'est antidémocratique là
pour le coup
la réalité c'est que déjà je pense que
nombreux français ne comprennent pas ce
système ni l'intérêt et le deuxième
c'est que ça empêche finalement de
rentrer dans la campagne en amont parce
qu'on ne sait pas qui vont être
finalement les candidats parrainés oui
je dirais pas que les français
comprennent pas le système parce qu'on
sait on pense principalement au maire
même s'il yad'autres d'autres élus comme
les conseillers départementaux les
conseils régionaux qui peuvent donner
leur lait leur signature
mais c'est peut-être comme l'on sait que
les maires sont les élus qui sont les
plus proches des français dépolitiser ce
qui est naturel puisque c'est eux qu'il
voit le plus régulièrement peut-être sa
tendance à rassurer les français quand
même que ce soit les maires qui donnent
leurs parrainages et pour l'instant
personne ne me semble utile n'a trouvé
de systèmes alternatifs qui serait
satisfaisant je crois que c'était eric
zemmour qui demandait qu'on crée un sur
deux poules de signature et on ne
distribuerait à peu près au hasard
ensuite aux candidats qu aurait été
sondé à 10% ce qui est complètement
absurde parce que dans ce cas là on
donne le pouvoir aux senteurs et aux
médias et dans ce cas là c'est cyril
hanouna qui élu demain fin mai
jeudi a pas de système pour l'installer
il fonctionne mais prononcé qu'on est
dans une contradiction de cette 5ème
république ait des modifications de la
vème république c'est à dire qu'on a le
quinquennat déjà dans ce qui fait que
les deux pouvoirs sont collés l'un à
l'autre ce qui fait qu'on a ce suffrage
universel direct qui a toujours besoin
de sortes de grands électeurs pour
présenter ses candidats et que les gens
demandent plus de démocratie comme le
référendum le référendum
l'impopulaire tout en demandant aussi
est-ce que ce soit les maires qu'ils
représentent du snes il ya une sorte de
contradiction il ya une solution qui
avait été proposé par lionel jospin
c'était le parrainage citoyen cent
cinquante mille citoyens qui peuvent
parrainer un candidat et ça a été géant
luc mélenchon nom de parrainage citoyen
donc demandé de dire voilà moi y'a plus
de cent cinquante mille citoyens
français qui veulent que je me présente
jean luc mélenchon l'a utilisé pour
l'avenir en commun et lionel jospin
l'avait proposé en 2000 également donc
on voit qu'il ya moyen de changer ce
système de le rendre peut-être plus
démocratique de le rendre plus lisible
et d'éviter justement cette
superposition de couches politique entre
les primaires les fausses primaires les
vrais prix bien le parrainage et les
candidats qui essayent finalement
d'exister médiatiquement le temps de la
campagne c'est vrai que il ya d'autres
moyens de faire que ce système là qui
paraissent stressant et de plus en plus
délicat je me demande si c'est pas une
fausse bonne idée vaut cent cinquante
mille signatures parce que ça demande
que un candidat et des moyens derrière
lui un appareil ou moins des moyens
techniques voire financiers pour pouvoir
aller recueillir ses 150 mille
signatures parce qu'il faut quand même
pouvoir faire sa propagande à voir le
lieu qu'ils aient recueillerait est allé
chercher le chèque signataires donc je
ne sais pas si on retomberait pas sur la
même chose que ça ne ferait pas
exploser ce système ce système actuel
mais notre question qui est intéressante
dans le convoi dans les parrainages
aujourd'hui et qui est qu'on peut parler
aujourd'hui ici je perds tes grâce à
l'excellent travail qui a été fait c'est
qu'elle est la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle des parrains de
chaque candidat mon intérêt c'est vrai
grâce à ce merveilleux qui a été fait on
voit que ça recoupe et 20
essentiellement ce que l'électorat de
chaque candidat évidemment qu emmanuel
macron lui pour l'instant dans les
parent qui l'a que les parrains déclaré
est quelqu'un qui recueille évidemment
beaucoup plus parmi les maires et autres
élus de cadres et professions
intellectuelles supérieures
c'est le cas aussi de valérie pécresse
alors qu on échange on voit qu'une
marine le pen évidemment est beaucoup
plus soutenu par des élus et des mères
qui sont des entrées vidéo ressemble en
gros le poujadisme si on peut dire et
puis pour jean luc mélenchon on voit
professions intellectuelles professions
intermédiaires du coup et c'est vrai que
chaque parrainage donne un peu déjà la
couleur du candidat et puis il ya aussi
autre chose c'est que plus de 71% de ses
signataires des parrainages sont des
hommes du fait de la structure de
l'électorat local en france donc il ya
aussi ce biais là et je peux voir que
par le parrainage déjà on donne une
couleur à un candidat c'est peut-être
important et c'est peut-être une bonne
chose justement ça permet déjà de
diversifier le la campagne de
diversifier la campagne mais on voit
quand même que
la perception qu'on a de chaque candidat
c'est-à-dire valérie pécresse ou
emmanuel macron comme le candidat des
riches et des professions
intellectuelles est quelque chose qui
est partagé par les élus eux mêmes et
ils viennent vraiment ce bloc ce bloc
bourgeois centrale qui est concurrencé
surtout à l'extrême droite par marine le
pen et par eric zemmour on se dit n'est
pas le cas en revanche jean luc
mélenchon de manière paradoxale qui est
le candidat de l'extrême gauche mais qui
est soutenu lui aussi par des pouvoirs
des élus de plutôt bourgeois ou plutôt
de csp + ce qu on parle d lui donc de
toutes façons déjà vous avez un filtre
qui fait qu'il ya quand même très peu
d'élus bande vont être ouvrier ou sans
emploi sur cinq et un petit village de
200 habitants c'est pas forcément les
pains de notaire qui est forcément l'élu
quand même un agriculteur en termes de
masse et de et de profil sociologique
des élus en france regardez l'assemblée
nationale par exemple on est très loin
d'une assemblée représentative des
français donc ça va être un peu le même
filtre sur les villes moyennes et les
grandes villes je parle pas des villages
évidemment où là c'est tout à fait
différent d'être merde une petite
commune que maire d'une grande
agglomération mais bon on n'a pas trouvé
aujourd'hui c'est le meilleur système ça
c'est sûr mais moi ce qui me qui
m'attriste c'est de voir à chaque fois
quand même la mise en scène de la quête
des parrainages c'est à dire la
d'appeler en disant attention nous ne
les avons pas alors on ne sait pas
quelle est la part de jeu quelle est la
part de réel marine le pen est
d'ailleurs celle qui joue le mieux un
jeu là à chaque fois donc on se dit mme
yap a besoin de se mobiliser finalement
elle va les avoir comme à chaque fois
mais à chaque fois elle essaye de faire
de la pub en fait de se victimiser de
dire je ne peux pas rentrer dans le
système le système est contre moi bon
c'est encore le cas
oui oui c'est le cas parce que rappelons
que l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
200 cellules très peu d'élus communs
comme 250 élus qui pourrait qu'ils sont
élus à l'assemblée nationale et
apparentés qui pourraient parrainer
mécaniquement marine le pen mais est
elle en a pour l'instant que 130 sur ces
250 qui ont donné leur signature ce qui
montre soit qu'il ya un problème à
l'intérieur de son parti qui faisait
dire rien passé troupe oui que les
autres vont partir chez eric zemmour
soit qu'elle est incapable avec ses
propres troupes d'aller chercher ces
signatures 20 points au simple point de
vue concret soit encore une fois qu'elle
joue à la victime pour montrer regarder
la méchante démocratie il veut me
refuser mais s'il ya sur le système
pardon le système alors que je suis la
candidate du peuple
direction le monde d'après alexis poulin
et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous jacques selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
[Musique]
et bien l'info à mon avis de la semaine
c'est le roux tellement c'est à dire
cette grande invention de fabien roussel
le candidat du parti communiste français
qui réussit une percée assez phénoménale
qui dû réussir à passer de un et demi à
4% donc c'est pas encore austerlitz mais
on s'en approche peut-être enfin ce
pastel nitrates non plus mais disons que
fabien roussel est le premier candidat
peut-être déjà parce que ces premiers
candidats communistes depuis 2007
ensuite il en avait pas présenté
puisqu'ils s'étaient ralliés au un bloc
des gauches qui est le premier candidat
depuis très très longtemps depuis 1969
où jacques duclos effet plus que le
candidat socialiste donc les premiers
candidats qui pour l'instant dans les
sondages est au dessus d'eux
l'inénarrable anne hidalgo candidate du
parti socialiste qui était lui-même au
pouvoir il ya cinq ans qui n'a qu'un an
et demi pour cent pourquoi parce que
fabien roussel me semble-t-il arrive à
avoir un discours que plus personne n'a
à gauche depuis assez longtemps c'est à
dire parler au peuple ce qui est assez
simple et parler au peuple en tant que
peuples enracinés français qui veulent
rester qui est capable de dire moi je
veux du nucléaire parce que c'est ça qui
nous fait vivre et manger je veux qu'on
puisse consommer du saucisson et du
pinard ce que c'est la bonne bouffe
française je veux que parler à ces gens
là qui sont oubliés et j'en ai rien à
duo qui soit je n'ai rien à foot
de l'islamo gauchisme et c'est ma ligne
c'est celle de celle du parti communiste
à la georges marchais sa proche du
peuple mais qui veut partir en congés
payés comme ça on a d'un côté un héros
qui veut faire le rpr et d'un côté un
russel qui veut faire le pcf de georges
marchais alors là la différence c'est
que le parti communiste et à l'époque de
georges marchais était encore à parti
révolutionnaire fabien roussel il a
lâché la révolution pour le saucisson
donc ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il est
un peu plus en odeur de sainteté pour
les cnp plus justement fin on le voit
c'est le candidat préféré de la droite
c'est le queens et de la droit fédéral
je pense pas parce qu'il parle quand
même de nationalisation encore qui reste
un gros mot à droite encore là encore de
bien sûr de de quelques lois sociales
mais on voit que le discours a changé
mais ça fonctionne dans les sondages ça
c'est sûr ça fonctionne reste à voir ce
qui se passera dans les yeux et plus
quelle quelle mécanique qui aura à
gauche puisque 4 % ça ne permet pas
d'aller très loin ni de rembourser la
campagne du parti communiste non mais
cette remontée quand même assez
inattendue est assez comique d'un parti
communiste français en 2022 moi je
voulais parler dans le monde d'après des
tractations qui commence ça y'est entre
yannick jadot et christiane taubira
après la primaire populaire l'idée
c'était de faire l'union de la gauche
derrière christiane taubira où un
candidat qui sortait de cette primaire
ça a été l or on voit bien que ces
tractations alors il ya eu un dîner qui
a eu lieu
un dimanche soir fâche beaucoup au sein
des écologistes notamment sandrine
rousseau qui avait terminé juste
derrière yannick jadot lors de la
primaire écologiste qui ne comprend pas
qui ne voudrait pas qu'on retombe dans
les travers de la politique politicienne
où on voit que c'est déjà peut-être une
union qui se dessine mais ça n'a jamais
permis non plus de gagner ni d'aller
très loin on se rappelle un déjà de ce
qui s'était passé les écologistes
s'étaient ralliés à benoît hamon pour un
score assez calamiteux lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 cette
fois ci je pense que yannick jadot ne
veux pas faire la même erreur donc il va
peut-être demander à madame taubira de
le rejoindre est ce qu'elle voudra faire
ça c'est une vraie question est est ce
que 4 + 5 font neuf et je ne sais pas
dans les sondages mais on voit bien
qu'il ya quelque chose là qui fâche
vraiment le camp écolo et qui fait qu'il
ya une vraie scission qui est en train
de se faire entre les partisans de son
des morceaux et les partisans des
initiés d'eau c'est très paradoxal parce
qu'on a du mal à voir idéologiquement ce
qui sépare quand même madame taubira de
madame rousseau ils sont quand même plus
tôt sur la même ligne et que ce serait
justement l'occasion d'un rassemblement
qui va créer une autre division
peut-être parce que madame rousseau ne
supporte pas qu'ils aient une
concurrence interne dans le parti avec
et christiane taubira donc que va faire
sandrine rousseau elle va partir dans
chez quelqu'un d'autre elle pourrait
rejouer la partie de l'avenir commun
puisqu'elle avait déjà le lancer des
ponts elle était l'université d'été de
jean luc mélenchon ce genre de choses
donc elle peut tout à fait décider d'un
coup de tonnerre de ce type là coup de
campagnes dont claudia de gauche comme
l'autre droite n'en parlais tout à
l'heure on arrive surtout pas à
s'entendre sur des personnalités puisque
dans le fond des discours il ya quand
même assez peu de différence on va voir
ça la semaine prochaine et très
rapidement on sera kiêu en tout cas on
en parle la prochaine foi dans le dieu
des éditos à très bientôt jacques très
bientôt alexis
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd e à la 6 prochaine
pour un nouveau duel des éditos
[Musique]